a coronavirus is the common cold
the common cold is incredibly
infectious the knee-jerk reaction was
probably the right
knee-jerk reaction but what are your
thoughts about the mask and hand
sanitizers
it's just so easy to do i mean i saw
your video about masks where you said it
doesn't work
this is the real deal and let's treat it
like the real deal
what's the total amount of heart
surgeries you think you've done well
over ten thousand
well over ten thousand what is the
different symptom between having a heart
attack and a panic attack
interestingly enough not much do you see
the link between the vaccine
and autism that's a new thing we never
used to poly vaccine kids do you tell
your
kids yeah it's okay let's take all the
shots or do you tell them to kind of
oh you don't no when i travel to africa
or india do i have to get vaccinated
yes i do do i take the flu vaccine no
never
never why not why don't you 16 chance of
it working one in six
why would i bother i'd rather arm myself
against the flu just like i am arming
myself and my patients against covet 19.
also you also wouldn't take the pfizer
vaccine if it comes out you wouldn't
take that shot
my guest today is dr steven gundry he's
got another nickname amongst us but it's
stephen gundry to
you he is a cardiac and heart surgeon
pre-med undergrad studies at yale
university
graduated [ __ ] laude and he got md from
medical college of georgia
holds several patents holds a record for
the longest surviving pig
to baboon heart transplant that is
absolutely something i want to know
about
he operated in over 30 countries
charitable in china india zimbabwe
new york time best-selling author the
planned paradox and for whatever reason
when he speaks millions listen it's
because he knows what he's talking about
and you're gonna love his approach more
than anything else
doc thank you so much for being a guest
on entertainment hey patrick thanks for
having me on
any time so you know some of us wake up
in the morning and we say you know what
one day when i grow up
i want to be a soldier i want to be a
police officer i want to go be a hero i
want to be a spy my
seven-year-old son right now told this
teacher when he grows up he wants to be
a spy i don't know what why that is but
he wants to be a spy
at what point did you know you wanted to
be a doctor and at what point did you
say i want to go be a
cardiac and heart surgeon
so i actually decided to become a doctor
when i was 10 years old
when i read a book in my public school
elementary school library called all
about you
and it was kind of all about you
and uh believe it or not in fourth grade
my
uh science project was how to do an epid
appendectomy that i did with the
illustrations
people fourth grade fourth grade uh that
complete illustrations people claim i uh
operated on my sister
to to do all the illustrations that's
not true um
but yeah so i knew actually from
a very early age that that's what i
wanted to do
and then when i when i got into medical
school
i at the medical college of georgia they
were
kind of way ahead of their time even a
first year medical student you would go
you'd be assigned a physician to kind of
follow
through their rounds even as a first
year medical student and
i was lucky to get assigned to
the head of pediatric cardiology who
was just really instrumental in in my
education
and then as time progressed
um we said um
well you know you're going to make a
great pediatric cardiologist and i said
well you know
his name was dr william strong by the
way um
and i said well you know that strong um
i think it's great
finding out what's wrong with kids
hearts and things like that but i want
to fix it and he said oh yeah what a
waste uh but okay
you know we'll uh if you want to be a
children's heart surgeon
uh we'll you know we'll get it done uh
so yeah so now i said from an early age
10 years old and you kind of had an idea
this is what you were going to do was
there any kind of an inspiration a
father mother uncle anybody
no you know looking back i think my
father always wanted to be a doctor
but quite frankly um he enlisted
in in world war ii and then
um he got
into two years of college but then he
married my mother and needed a job
um so maybe i lived through him
interestingly enough my mother was
um valedictorian of her high school
class in a class of 700 people in omaha
nebraska at central high
wow and i think had it been a different
era um she would not
have become a housewife
but uh she was really instrumental
from day one in
making the most i guess out of me
um and you know i credit a huge amount
to her
i i ended up salutatorian in a class of
720 so
you know my mother beat me so what the
heck
it's always interesting you know because
uh you see these stories there's a one
uh
speaker on tedx i think she's got 20
million views and
she decided to go study what it is to be
a brain
surgeon because her brother
when she was growing up had an aneurism
and she fully said for the rest of my
life
i don't know if you know the story or
not really interesting story
and you see that typically happen with
some kind of an inspiration because
father had a heart attack mother had a
heart attack i thought there was
something there
but okay that's great so you became a
cardiac heart surgeon uh for folks who
are
watching this when it says you've
operated in 30 different countries
what does that look like i mean you you
get invited do you go is it all
charitable how does that work out
yeah both um i
became a very very famous heart surgeon
um
designed a lot of operations several of
which carry my name
design patented methods of protecting
the heart
during heart surgery and made patented
some catheters
and so yeah i would be invited as a
visiting professor
around the world and you know scrub in
and teach doctors how to do something
but i also
as professor and chairman at loma linda
university became part
of their uh charitable work around the
world
we would take a team and fly into
zimbabwe for instance and operate
on children for a couple of weeks donate
our time
and uh done it in china done it in
india so it's uh yeah a little both
it's very cool uh is it is it pretty
common that
a lot of cardiologists have your
personality because my my dad's had 13
heart attacks the guys had six
angiograms six angioplastics three
stents in his heart
i can tell you each time he had a heart
attack now he drank for two decades
straight and smoked two packs a day
for three decades so he knows why he had
it he's doing very good today 78 years
old
knock on wood he's made it because he
changed his lifestyle and we're so glad
and proud of them
but is it common that cardiologists have
personalities like you're so calm
easy going or is it just you because i
don't know why i keep running into
cardiologists with your kind of
personality
no actually i was told when i decided to
become a heart surgeon that there was no
way
i could be a heart surgeon because i was
too nice a guy
and most most heart surgeons
have at least the reputation of being
uh ice in their veins top gun
fighter pilots uh get in get out
um in fact interesting
aside i was the consultant to the movie
the doctor
that starred william hurt and
it's actually it's a true story i didn't
write the book but it's a true story
about a physician
who is a heart surgeon who
was the typical kind of ice man
ice in his veins jerk and
uh he develops cancer and it's
his story of being treated
uh by people who
really didn't care they were just icemen
and he realized
what a jerk he was and it totally
changed his life
of being on the receiving end of of him
and it was it's actually a very
inspirational story
i bet to go from you know being someone
who's eyes to all of a sudden you're the
one that's on the bed and someone has to
take care of you and you're kind of
humbled
life has a way about itself you know how
it goes so
let's talk a little bit about uh uh
heart attacks
and i got five topics with you that i
want to go through one of them is
what's your an expertise expert in which
is doing cardiac and heart surgeries
in the world of business you're in
pressure a lot
a lot you're having to make ends meet
when you're starting the business you
have to hit
numbers you hire people you fire people
you're hated sometimes you got
competitors
you got defamation of character you got
rumors you got challenges you got
running out of money you got economy you
got market you got all this stuff that's
going on
and you have to take care of your family
your wife your husband your kids
all the stuff you're dealing with
obviously there's a lot of pressure
right a lot of pressure that builds up
and many times you know i'm in a lot of
different circles amongst other
entrepreneurs that are running good
sized businesses
what's starting to happen a lot that's
coming up to me and i kind of want to
run this by you and see
what your take will be on this is
a lot a lot of people are experiencing
panic attacks and anxiety attacks and
they're wondering
if it's a heart attack okay and so you
have a very similar symptom here your
chest feels heavy
your palms get sweaty you feel a lot of
pressure like an elephant that's
stepping on your chest
and then you realize it's a panic attack
you go to the hospital saying no you're
not having a heart attack you're totally
fine
it's a panic attack what is the
difference symptom between having a
heart attack and a panic attack
interestingly enough not much and
so many times
particularly in the emergency room when
someone like this comes in
luckily there are blood tests that are
available to tell the difference right
away
within you know 30 minutes that it's a
panic attack versus a heart attack or
there are no ekg
changes for instance on a heart tracing
but there's particularly i think
you're right there is a
high level of
anxiety particularly obviously for the
last
six months with covid19
and we're seeing a lot of people
presenting with
anxiety interestingly enough as an aside
most people think that when they're
under a lot of stress their
cortisol levels are high and
that's why things are going so wrong
conversely as i talk about in my
upcoming book the energy paradox a lot
of people think
the same thing is adrenal fatigue
that they burned out their adrenals
because of the stress
and i can assure you and your listeners
and viewers that
about 95 of people who think
they have anxiety or high cortisol
or conversely adrenal fatigue have
absolutely normal cortisol levels
absolutely normal and it's
cortisol and adrenal fatigue is
unfortunately
it's one of those wonderful internet
myths and it sells books
um but it's it's
very very rare so similar symptoms
similar feel everything's the same so so
when i when i when i hear people telling
me because i watch my dad go
through a lot of heart attacks himself
so he would say you feel pain
here your jaw almost tightens up a
little bit right
and the pressure is a little bit center
a little bit left i don't know if that's
correct your left arm tightens up
a little bit of your left leg any other
symptoms that you notice from all the
patients you've dealt with all these
years well interesting women
have very very different symptoms uh you
know
you're you're describing typical male
symptoms uh certainly the elephant
sitting on your chest is another good
example
women unfortunately often
have none of these and women more often
will talk about having a queasy feeling
in their stomach
or having a sense of nausea
or belching or burping and
that frequently is they'll just go oh
that's indigestion and what the heck
you know i'll i'll ignore it i'll take a
you know a couple of tums and i'll ride
this out
and interestingly when you start
actually talking with men the number of
men
through the years that have angina
or narrowings in their coronary arteries
oftentimes they will attribute this to
heartburn and i'll tell you a funny
story back
in the early days before modern tests
we used to joke as heart and
esophagus surgeons that half the time
people we did bypasses on what they
actually had was heartburn
and half the time people who we would
operate on their esophagus
for reflux they actually had coronary
artery disease we just didn't have
the ability to tell the difference and i
think
so a lot of particularly you know the
the lay public
number one men in particular
are great deniers um of
ah you know it's a it's a toothache or
uh ah you know i had too many spicy
meatballs tonight and i'll just go to
bed
um women because i think of their role
as the matriarch of the family
don't want to bother anybody and quite
frankly
physicians to this day
study that's ever been done show that
physicians
do not give as much credibility to a
woman's complaint
as to a man's complaint and
much of women's heart disease is missed
or ignored until often it's too late
so why is that
um you know don't get me started but
for the last curious well for the last
20 years
um in my new role in in restorative
medicine teaching people how to reverse
diseases rather than operating on them
i've come to realize that
women just as a general rule get
real short shrift from health care
providers
their complaints are and i was taught
this um their complaints are not to be
believed
they're they're hysterical they're
emotional
um this is all in their head
and one of the things that i guess has
made me
famous is that i've come to learn
from my patients many of whom are women
with autoimmune diseases that
believe it or not it is not in women's
head and if
if a woman has a complaint it's
it's to be taken seriously now
i'm you know i'm a father of two
daughters and i'm
married to a woman and i have three
female dogs so
maybe i'm biased from that but i think
one of the things
we as a profession
uh we really have not given women their
do
in listening to their complaints
that's uh that that's i just pulled up a
stat while you were saying this to just
kind of look at the numbers
this is from caring seniorservice.com
uh men experience heart attacks more
than women
between 789 percent of sudden heart
attacks are experienced by
men not women why why do you think
men have more heart attacks than women
do
well it's number one men
tend to ignore
what they should be paying attention to
um
if if if i had
you can't believe the number of men who
for instance
are out on a golf course and
have an issue i mean they've got an
elephant sitting on their chest
and they go ah you know it's just hot
out here and i'll go have a beer
and the elephant's still sitting on
their chest ah you know it was just
a little heat stroke and i'll go home
and then the next thing you know at two
o'clock in the morning
uh somebody's pounding on their chest
and you know i'm whipping him into the
operating room they've had a massive
heart attack
and they just
men are really good at denial um
we're really good at it i would agree
with that 100 yeah
i would totally agree with that you you
think you think half of it is just our
pride and ego of being untouchable i
have to play this role of this tough guy
that i don't have to go see the doctor i
don't need it it's not a big deal i'm
okay i'm gonna be fun do you think it's
more that macho thing that we have to be
this tough guy
i think it's part of that i think the
other part is
uh this it it can't happen to me i
you know i'm in such good shape uh
that's nonsense that's not what i'm
having
a doc have you ever had a heart attack
yourself better not no
i was going to say no but the only
reason i ask is because for you to know
so if you've never had a heart attack
yourself
to the average person who you know
because i'm you've written the books you
know new york times bestseller there's a
number of books
you've written on health you know the
planned paradox you're talking about the
energy paradox that's coming out i think
march of 2021
which is very exciting to see that one
coming out but for the average person
that's not in your world that they're
just living their lives they're trying
to pay their bills they're trying to
build their business they're trying to
move up in life and at the same time
enjoy their lives
one how do we go about preventing like
one is preventative what can i do from
the preventative standpoint
two is you know is there ages like i
went to the doctor this week
uh to do my physical and the nurse comes
on she says have you ever done a uh
colonoscopy i said no she says how are
you i said 42.
she said oh you'll do that when you're
hitting 50. oh okay interesting you know
maybe that's something you do in your
50s okay great
what are some is there a preventative
things i need to be worried about in my
20s 30s 40s 50s
you know how often i go see the doctor
what are some things i can do where i
don't have to
one day sit there saying why am i having
this elephant on my chest
well there's a there's a number of
things you can do
and it's actually never too early to
start
doing it one thing i've told anyone who
will listen
and you probably have never had it
measured
most doctors will measure of fasting
glucose which is a fasting blood sugar
a lot of doctors will measure what's
called hemoglobin a1c
and if you if you watch commercials i
got my
a1c down hemoglobin a1c
in general looks at an average for the
two months
prior to the blood test of how much
sugar and how much protein you're
handling and we use hemoglobin a1c
to look at diabetes pre-diabetes
and uh as i tell anyone who will listen
telling somebody they're a pre-diabetic
is like telling a woman she's a little
bit pregnant
there's no difference between
pre-diabetes and diabetes
which leads me into i think if i tell
people if there is
one blood test that and all you get is
one
and it's an eight dollar blood test you
want to get a
fasting insulin level
and if that fasting insulin level
is above nine
i can tell you that lots of
bad things are in store for you
going forward it is so
predictive of developing heart disease
developing diabetes of developing cancer
developing memory loss parkinson's
alzheimer's dementia like i say if i had
one test that's what i would order and
i have a third year um
residents in family medicine rotate
through my
clinic for a month and this is their
third year before they go out into
practice
and not one so far
of these residents have ever heard
of ordering a fasting insulin level and
don't know the significance of that
the other thing if i had two
tests is i would get
a triglyceride
and hdl level
i quite frankly could care less about
total cholesterol
i could care less about ldl the
so-called bad cholesterol
what i want to know is the triglycerides
which are the first form of fat
that you manufacture from sugars and
starches
and i want to know hdl which is the
quote
good cholesterol and one of the best
predictors
of never ever ever getting heart disease
is your hdl and triglycerides should
preferably be equal
and if if possible your hdl should be
higher than triglycerides so those are
a couple of simple tests to hang your
hat on
so okay so i say i go take this fasting
insulin
insulin test okay and it's above
nine and i have bad things in store
there's bad things coming
uh my way many many different things
that you just talked about right
yeah one what can i do to not get to
that point
and then two if i am at that point what
are my next five moves what do i do next
so can i give you my personal example
sure yes
all right so uh let's back
up over 20 years now
here i am at the top of my career
in heart surgery and i
meet a guy who i talk about in the plant
paradox by the name of big ed
um from miami who's got inoperable
coronary artery disease
cut to the chase by following a diet
that
looks like mine now and taking a bunch
of supplements from a health food store
the guy drops 45 pounds
and he reverses his inoperable coronary
artery disease
now what was so interesting at that time
at the height of my career
i had a fasting insulin level of 16
which is insulin resistance pre-diabetes
whatever you want
i had a triglyceride level of 166
and my hdl was 32. that doesn't sound
like one to one to me uh
i had i was obese uh even though i was
running 30 miles a week i was going to
the gym one hour a day i was doing 5k
10ks on the weekends i was what was
called a clydesdale runner
which is a big fat runner and
yet i had high blood pressure i had
pre-diabetes i had such bad arthritis
i had braces on my knees to run and i
had this crazy cholesterol profile
and i had no idea that i was insulin
resistant
fast forward three months
my insulin level drops to three
my triglycerides dropped to 30 my hdl
goes to 82.
i lose 50 pounds my first year i drop
another 20 pounds and i've
kept it off for 20 years
and so i had
all the markers of man i'm gonna have
heart disease like my dad
you know it's genetic yeah i totally
flipped that around
by changing what i ate and so
i devoted my career
to teaching people how to avoid me
which is really dumb as a heart surgeon
talk about a dumb career move
i mean really but i think that's why
people love you though you you are
genuinely loved by people because you're
you're the doctor you're the father
you're the uncle
any guy would love to have because the
way you talk
you make me want to take your counsel
versus sometimes doctors speak to you
like you're stupid
your approach is so well received by the
audience
well the other thing that i've promised
everyone who
listens to me is that for instance in my
first book which was published in 2006
uh 2007 sorry dr gundry's diet evolution
i've changed my views
based on my continuing research on my
patients
who allow me to take their blood every
three months and ask them to do
you know here don't eat that food or go
to costco and get that supplement
and so my views have changed i i've
evolved
my you know my teachings and
what frustrates me is that i have a
number of
famous colleagues who despite
20 years of advancement in research
haven't changed their views one iota on
you know what we should do and let me
give you
can i give you an example phrase from
this morning
so there are there's a famous
well-controlled diet study on
the prevention of heart disease and it's
called the
lion heart diet it's spelled l-y-o-n
it's leon but everybody calls it the
lion heart
diet study and what they did is they
took
people who had a heart attack
and they divided them into two groups
and it was uh
controlled for five years one group
was going to follow the american heart
association low-fat diet
and okay that's that's the american
heart association low-fat diet
the other group had to follow a
mediterranean diet but they had to
supplement their diet with um
a fat called alpha linoleic acid
now alkalinic like acid is present
in canola oil not much but
a lot flaxseed oil is loaded with that
the best source is perilla oil which is
the
favorite oil of korean cooking and a lot
of japanese cooking
anya they were supplemented with this
oil
at the end of three years the study was
stopped because the group with the
mediterranean diet
and the alpha linoleic acid had
so much fewer new events
fewer heart attacks that it was
unethical
to continue the study it was stopped
and so they
continued the study for five years
because the other
the one group that was having that diet
and the results continued for five years
now so it's been
well shown and that's just one of the
most famous studies
that a mediterranean diet with alpha
linoleic
acid in it beats the american heart
association low-fat diet and when all
this was broken down
it turns out that the only difference
that they could find in any blood test
between the two groups
was the amount of ala alpha linoleic
acid in the blood of
the two groups and the higher the better
the outcome
now what that tells you is um
have yourself some perilla oil every day
and
but so getting back to
this this morning i got an email from a
patient
whose doctor uh really
hated the fact that he was on my program
and
that he has a history of heart disease
and for god's sake man whatever you do
you have to start the american heart
association diet
right now and it's like
really don't don't you
read the literature do you want to have
a 30
higher rate of heart disease um
yeah that's what this is what we're up
against yeah i mean look
i was talking to you about my doctor
early when i said my dad's doctor dr
munaf shamji i want to give him a shout
out he's a very nice man he's been so
good to my dad
he treats him like his own dad and and
that's what i want when a doctor treats
my dad like his own dad or
his own family you know you get that
good feeling but sometimes
you talk to some doctors not all of them
some of them are going to make you feel
like uh
you have to stick to this guideline or
else you know kind of it's a little bit
too much there but
you know going back to what you did as a
doctor look um
i don't i don't know if this is for you
like how many total surgeries would you
say you've done
what's the total amount of heart
surgeries you think you've done no well
over ten thousand
well over ten thousand okay i wanna ask
you a question you can totally
decline to answer this one but uh you
know
for for being in the military
the last thing you wanted to do was
deliver any kind of bad news to anyone
and sometimes you have to deliver bad
news to
someone's spouse and hey your husband is
there or your son is there it's a very
painful thing to do
and that job i know a couple of my
friends who had that job
let me tell you when their day was over
with you you did not want to look at
them because they just sometimes it was
not a
easy day for them and that's their job
that's what they're supposed to do some
of them that had been around for a
little long time
still hurt them but they knew was part
of the job have you ever lost patients
and if you did
what was the first someone that happened
to you what was your reaction the first
time it happened to you
well one of the things um that you do
have to have in your head
going in is that you
are not going to lose this patient that
there's no way that you would even
go in thinking that you would
and it's it's like um
what terry bradshaw used to say every
pass i
ever threw was for a touchdown
when it left my hand and i think that's
the same sort of attitude you have to
have i
i became famous as a surgeon who would
operate
on people who were inoperable who were
turned down
and so i knew going in that
some people were not going to make it
out
and i've had in the years i had people
who
i would have never guessed that they you
know
were not going to make it through the
surgery um
and yet looking back the family would go
and say gosh you know
we went back to the house and mom had
made
casseroles for dad for two weeks
and she left notes of you know here's
where everything is
you know it's like she knew and you know
i'd go why didn't she tell me
but one of the things uh there's a
famous
saying that that surgeons carry around
a cemetery in their head and if you're a
good surgeon you
visit that cemetery and you
you go to that cemetery to learn
from the people that didn't come out
alive
and you know what could you have done
differently and i think
i hope that that's what makes a good
surgeon
from a not so good surgeon i i knew a
heart surgeon
that lost patients and that surgeon
would say
poor bastard it was just his time
you can't do that you have to you have
to learn
from the people who don't make it and
you know what would i have done
differently
i'll give you another great example i
was talking about this earlier i
have a patient who's now 15
years from the time i was scheduled to
take him into the operating room he had
had a massive heart attack
he had five vessel coronary artery
disease we scheduled him for surgery
we're down going into the operating room
and he looks at me he says doc
i'm scared to death he says i don't
think i'm gonna make it
and i said well wait a minute yeah good
okay i'm glad you feel this way
because i take this seriously he says
isn't there any other way
and i said well yeah i said look if you
become
my best patient i promise you
you will never be operated on you know
by me or anybody else
i said but you got to promise to be my
best patient he said oh i'll do anything
i'll do anything
we just celebrated his 15th year
from me not operating on him wow
he was a bad diabetic he now passes his
stress tests
we joke about it that's cool yeah
and so it's never too late which is
one of the messages but yeah you got a
yeah you're right uh and i was a
children's heart surgeon too and there's
you know it's it's one thing to maybe
you know lose somebody who's had a great
life and they're
80 or 85 but it's another thing when
it's a newborn baby
or a two-year-old or three-year-old that
has their entire hopefully life ahead of
them
and they don't they don't make it now
the only reason we operate on these
children is because they
have no future unless we are able to put
their hearts back together
but still it doesn't make it any easier
to
to live with that um so you
you have to you have to have a cemetery
you visit
and luckily i have one um
i was actually visiting that cemetery
this morning um
just to visit it
yeah to me i can only imagine how
emotional it can be you know for
for somebody who does it like the way
you're saying it right now where
you have that relationship to to sit
down with a patient and say if you
listen to me
15 years when my dad had his first heart
attack
94 i can tell you exactly where i was i
came out of high school i was in 10th
grade
i was at the kitchen off of broadway
1323 broadway my friend art was there
with me my mom's cooking something my
sister calls me
saying dad had a heart attack and i ran
to the hospital
and saw him there it was a interesting
moment but my dad listened to his doctor
and the doctor said maybe you got 10
more years if you make this
that's 94 from a massive heart attack
here until today
so i salute doctors like yourself out
there what you do is
patriotic we need people like you to do
what you do because without you
there'll be a lot of people out there
that wouldn't have those additional
years with their families so so salute
to
folks like you that do what you do on a
daily basis i appreciate you personally
personally for sharing that uh wisdom
and perspective with us so i think
that's
the cardiac section we can go to the
next section that uh we can go to a
complete different topic here
uh uh let's talk a little bit about
coronavirus
yeah so coronavirus um
you've you've been around if you've done
ten thousand surgeries in your lifetime
you've been around for a while have you
ever seen a time
uh i've only been in a state since
november 28 1990 which is
30 years is coming up in two weeks have
you ever seen a time
where a virus has
scared americans as much as this has
where it's
forced the government to shut us down
and handle the way with i mean we've
experienced aids cancer a lot of
different things that we've had
but i've never seen the reaction at
least myself i've never seen it but
yourself maybe you have a different
perspective on this what do you think
about the reaction american the world
said to coronavirus
no i mean we've we've never had anything
like this the the closest thing was the
h1n1
uh flu uh but
luckily it wasn't even close back then
we thought that that was
you know potentially going to be the
next the next pandemic
and we if you remember we really thought
that maybe the sars
virus the original or mers
was going to be the next pandemic but
luckily
for whatever reason neither of those
panned out
but yeah this coronavirus um
i don't want to say we were caught
flat-footed because i think there were a
lot of people
who saw the writing on the wall saw the
writing on the wall
quite early and for
we could spend all day talking about
this for whatever reasons
we didn't do a good job let me just give
you a california example
one of the things that that happened to
us in california
is that that very early on uh gavin
newsom
uh shut california down
and shut it down early and shut it
locked it down hard and
we never really got you know that
initial big spike that
new york had or washington had and
we did very well and then
i think we opened up too early
and it was memorial day i can
i can remember uh was actually walking
on the beach in santa barbara on
memorial day
and there was still a rule that you
could not sit on the beach you could not
gather on the beach but the b the
beaches had actually been locked down
you you couldn't even walk on the beach
so memorial
memorial day came the beach was more
crowded
with more human beings than we had ever
seen
on july 4th uh i mean
it was insane we actually turned around
and
left and we went what the heck well
two weeks after that you know we
started our first spike and we had
opened up the bars and we had opened up
the restaurants
and luckily uh we
you know clamped down we didn't clamp
down as hard
but whenever you see these sorts of
events
and it's happened everywhere
it always these spikes follow these
these openings now you can't stay closed
forever
and one of the things i wrote an
editorial in thrive
global a few months ago i think one of
the mistakes we've made
is we let's use the world war ii analogy
we could not stay in in the bunkers in
england
for five years while germany was
dropping bombs on london
waiting to develop the atomic bomb the
manhattan project
nobody would have been able to do that
but what
churchill says is you know we are going
to fight him in the air we're going to
fight him on the beaches we're going to
fight him on the land
we're going to arm ourselves we're going
to equip our troops
and we're going to fight and what we
haven't done
is we have not fought
this virus personally with what we
know can actually help us
fight this virus and
if we applied what we already know
about preventing ourselves from number
one
catching this virus and number two
if we get this virus making it a
mild illness rather than a lethal
illness
we'd be so far ahead already uh so maybe
that's a good intro to
maybe where you want to talk about yeah
i'm just wondering because you know i
so i remember where i was at when i'm
having a board meeting in la and i get a
call all my board members are not coming
from greenwich in new york i'm like what
are you guys talking about oh it's
coronavirus
you're serious yeah it's march 12th i
think that's the day
nhl nba shut down and disney and
everybody was shutting down
you guys are really not coming in late
no we're not coming this is serious
okay so i start calling her on and then
i come back and i come back to want to
do my own research
and bring my wife mikey we were planning
on going to universal studios i said why
are we staying here because if this has
happened let's just go back to dallas so
we came back to dallas
and when i go back and i look at data
that i pulled up with sars
mers ebola any of the ones that you look
at
none of them we knew how bad they were
going to be
none of them do we really have the real
are not score on how
infectious it is right how how quickly
is it going to spread right
just like covet we didn't know yet we
didn't have that kind of data
it's not long enough for us to know that
kind of data
why is it that we didn't shut down with
the other viruses that they showed up
but we shut down with
this virus and how do we make a decision
like that because for me
you know how you want to go buy a house
or you're selling your house when you
want to sell your house you call your
realtor say i want to sell this house
what should we sell it for
let me look at the comps okay what's a
sell it for i know you want to sell a 4
million
but your house is probably an 8.50 i
think it's a million
it's not a million it's 8.50 and you
have this argument with your realtor and
then you get off the phone you talk to
your wife and you say she has no clue
what she's talking about the realtor
and then you finally realize she has a
clue what she's talking about he said
let's put it for 8.99 okay
who gets the comps to say how do we
handle
other viruses in the past if we've never
shut
it down on any virus
how much data do we have to say let's
shut it down now what is your
you know response to that one because to
me there's a part of me that wonders was
it a reaction was it an overreaction
was it an under i mean how do we know
where does the intel come from to say
it's the best thing to do right now is
to shut down
well i think let's talk from the united
states
we we did have
intel uh coming out of wuhan
and we did have intel coming out of
italy
um early on that this
this guy was a bigger mischief maker
than anyone would have predicted i mean
after all this is a coronavirus is
the common cold so one of the
the things that i think we should have
guessed
is that the common cold is incredibly
infectious it has an infectivity rate
that is so infectious that we take it
for granted
you know oh you know i'm i'm going to
get a cold this winter and
oh well you know i i i know i'm going to
get one
and you know the person next to me
sneezing is going to give me a cold or
you know
shaking hands i'm going to get a cold so
i guess we should have known that from
day one
this coronavirus is is highly infected
i think the other thing that we
luckily knew from wuhan and particularly
italy
is that this uh we didn't know why it
was but this had the ability to
overwhelm our
icu and ventilator capacity and
that was different than sars and mirrors
and it was even different than the n1
h1n1
flew and very early on
we you know again the evidence out of
both
wuhan and milan well in bergamo was that
this had the capacity to i mean just
literally wipe out our ability to
to take care of people so i think
at that point the the knee-jerk reaction
which
i'm actually i think the knee-jerk
reaction was
probably the right knee-jerk reaction um
just to you know prevent overwhelming
facilities and
again we're starting right now to get
right where we were you know at in march
is
we're we're heading to overwhelming
facilities that
have no ability to keep up with us and
in places where
one wouldn't have ever imagined it um
yeah
you know i'm originally from the midwest
and the idea that north dakota
you know would have been epicenter of of
overwhelming their you know their
hospitals is like oh yeah right
you know we're all farmers who's going
to get infected
uh so night and day with north and south
though if you know if you look at what
south asian versus north very
interesting how north got
hit but south was you know good to go
and south had a different approach to it
than north took it's very interesting
what they did there
yep yeah so so okay so fair enough so
so then the next question from your
optics becomes
we're gonna have another virus in the
next 5 10 15 20 years this is not going
away it's not like
7.7 billion people are not going to
create more viruses
do you think this becomes the standard
for moving forward when we do have
another one any president that's the
sitting president
is going to be pressured to bring their
you know
expert from cdc whoever whoever that
doctor fought you of 2028 is going to be
or 2039 is going to be
to say yep i think we got to do what we
did in 2020 let's shut it down for six
weeks
do you think that kind of becomes a
standard well yeah you know the other
thing that's happened to us
we've all of us uh
have been used to global travel um
think nothing of getting on a plane or
getting on a boat
and flying all over the world just
instantaneously and think nothing about
that
and i think
as a consequence of that we've
now with this global economy um
we're gonna and it will open up again i
have no doubt about it um
and we'll get back to quote normal
and that will just put us in a position
for the
next great virus
to you know to do it again um
you know we forget that you know the
spanish flu
which uh by the way happened and started
in kansas
i hope most people know that uh u.s
troops that were trained in kansas
actually caught the spanish flu and gave
it to the world
but um and so the idea that this is the
chinese flu is sorry we didn't so you
don't think it happened you don't think
it started in china you don't think it's
okay
no i but let's remember that
our coronavirus arkova 19
is the european mutation
of the chinese virus so
arkova 19 is the mutant so
we have the european um
believe it or not the chinese virus
of covid was very isolated to washington
state
and a bit of oregon but the rest of us
all came in through new york new jersey
washington dc
uh from europe uh so if you want to call
it let's call it the european virus um
it's better name but it's silly putting
a name on this stuff
but yeah we're going to have another one
yeah i'm just wondering if it's a
standard like does a standard become
the next one we have to shut it down
again the next one we have to shut it
down again just to make sure we don't
make uh
because it's so much risk if you don't
shut it down right
well i think again i think we have to
for
this one this guy right away
in wuhan before they even knew what this
was there were
scientists saying this is really weird
people are getting pneumonia and they're
they're getting on a ventilator and we
have
no idea why everybody who's coming in
with this illness
is winding up on a ventilator and dying
we don't know what's going on
so i think that's different um for
instance
the flu absolutely kills lots of people
i
can name numbers of people that i've
cared for with flu
but what was happening with the flu is
that these people
got a consequence of having the flu
they had a heart attack or
they caught a pneumonia bacterial
pneumonia
or they had kidney failure but they
didn't
die from the flu
and we we have to make that distinction
it's the sequelae of having the flu
that you die from not the flu in this
one
it was holy cow there's something weird
going on because people are coming in
here and they're sick
and they're all ending up on a
ventilator and you could count on
you know one hand the number of people
i've ever had to put on a ventilator who
walked in on with the flu
um so it was a totally different animal
and so hopefully the next
whatever virus it is and who knows what
it's going to be
hopefully it may not appear in this way
uh maybe you know this virus will go
maybe this virus will attack the heart
more than this one does maybe this virus
will attack the kidneys and we just
don't know
from from watching it in your world of
expertise and how
uh we learned this one because again
this one leaves data for the rest
how do you think we could have handled
it differently this time around so we do
the right time
next time when we do get one meaning if
you're watching and saying
you know here's fauci we shut down china
we what could we have done differently i
know when
even originally when fauci said there's
no way in the world we're going to get a
vaccine within
18 months and within nine months
pfizer's coming out with the vaccine
that could potentially be ready it's a
efficacy he himself didn't think that
was going to be taking place so for vag
for
them to announce that it's a pretty big
deal what do we learn from this one that
we could have done differently for the
next time around
well that gets back to what i uh
what we talked about before so the
people who are at risk for this virus
for the most part
have pre-existing conditions and if you
actually look
at what pre-existing conditions are
we're talking about obesity
we're talking about pre-diabetes we're
talking about
insulin resistance we're talking about
hypertension we're talking about heart
disease
we're we're talking about being on
medications
now hippocrates 2500 years ago
said that all disease begins in the gut
and one of the things i've learned is
i don't know how he knew this but the
guy was absolutely right and in fact
i'll pull away
and maybe your viewers can see this
the road to health is paved with good
intestines
and what what i've
tried to convince people is that
if you do not have
a leaky gut and if you
do not have insulin resistance
then your chance of getting
covet is quite low and if you
get coveted it is going to be a mild
illness
now let me bring that home for an
example from last week i have i saw a
woman
who's been a patient from mine who's a
who's a snow bird
um she and her husband are she's 85
he's 86. she's been my patient
he laughs at the fact that she does all
this crazy stuff with me
they caught covid in march um
and she um
the it's night and day she had it for 48
hours she says
yeah you know it's kind of like the flu
he ended up in the icu for 45 days
um nearly didn't make it
uh it was touch and go but he's just
recently gotten out of the hospital this
was he went in for
five days wow 45 days in the icu on a
ventilator
and one of the things we've done with
her
is we've kept her vitamin d level
above 100 as i do with all my patients
most docs say that's toxic i can assure
you it's not
there's now six different human studies
that show
people with high vitamin d the higher
the vitamin d
the less likely you are to catch covet
and if you catch it it's going to be
mild
the lower your vitamin d the more likely
you are to catch covid and the worse
it's going to be
and here's 85 year olds who couldn't
have been
night and day different she followed
what i asked her to do we knew what her
vitamin d levels were
for instance her vitamin d when i saw
her last week was 105.
and she said boy is he listening to
me now
vitamin d levels of 100 interesting
yeah well that's that's uh uh that's
good to know because for you know for
for for me everything to me is you know
i wrote a book called your next five
moves everything's about
what are we going to do next what are
our next five moves after knowing
so now that we know this is what's going
to happen the next pandemic
what could we do to make sure the same
thing doesn't happen because we don't
want to get
what 45 million unemployed getting
checks from the government restaurants
shutting down businesses shutting down a
lot of people are affected by it and
sometimes
when you lose your business you can't
just go start up another business
because your life savings went into it
you got to go get another
job but there's got to be businesses to
have another job so
what do you think the psychological you
know
repercussions or side effects we're
going to see from the folks that had to
go through these shutdowns especially
different states
the state uranus kids can't go to school
they're at stay home you know you're in
california
palm springs santa barbara new york same
thing texas at least they're letting
kids to go to school
but not every state's the same what are
the psychological side effects that
we're gonna see from this come
a year two years five years ten years
from now well let me
let me just finish one more thought on
where we were just now
i'll take your questions please the best
defense is a good offense
and let me bring back world war ii in
world war ii there
was rationing there was sugar rationing
there was flower rationing
and in the countries that rationed the
united states britain norway
just to use an example net denmark we
had
drastic reductions
in heart attacks and diabetes
in mortality from 1940 to 1945
in all of these countries that underwent
rationing
we planted victory gardens in the united
states
40 of all the food
eaten during world war ii in the united
states
was grown in backyard victory gardens 40
so what we know is that if we
for instance get rid of our processed
foods get rid of our highly processed
food
plant a victory garden you can do it on
your stoop for one thing
and let's arm ourselves we know that
this
worked in world war ii and this was my
editorial
let's not let the virus get us let's arm
ourselves against getting the virus
and if we don't have pre-existing
conditions guess what
the chance of this thing doing anything
to us is very
minimal and that's the whole point so
let's be ready because the next one's
coming i mean if i agree
if anything we're going to learn from
this is guess what the next one's coming
you know the obama administration knew
this there was a pandemic task force
that
was disbanded but you know everybody
knew this
um and but let's prepare
personally to you know meet this thing
head on
rather than just waiting for what's
coming
okay so uh you're right uh
i have two lovely grandchildren my
uh my daughter and her husband my
daughter is a high school
teacher and my grandkids
are four and a half and seven
and she's homeschooling them and we talk
all the time and she says this is
driving me absolutely crazy and i said
well wait wait wait a minute
you're a teacher you know you have a
degree
i am not a first grade and kindergarten
teacher i'm a high school math and
physics teacher
it's this is driving me might be
different yeah it's slightly different
and i said
i said well you know that's actually
very valuable information because i
figured you'd go yeah
i got this but no and
yeah it's the the psych psychological
toll on this is just um
it's devastating and to say nothing
you're right uh
i do think that we have to
look that at all of this
awfulness there is always
something that is going there's going to
be something that benefits you
uh it may not seem like it but there is
going to be something that benefits us
um i can't tell you the number of people
who have been in a job that they hate
and for one reason or another they no
longer
have that job and it is
it was their opportunity to
start something that they actually loved
and i hear from these people all the
time
that you know this is the best thing
that ever happened to them even though
at the time
it certainly didn't seem that way and
we could i'm sure you've heard the
stories as well but
um there's
it sounds trite but everything happens
for a reason
and the longer i've been at this
including in my career
uh you i wouldn't have believed it when
bad things happened to me
but in retrospect it was
some of the best bad things that ever
happened to me
yeah it's it's it's uh i just wonder you
know i wonder what we're gonna some of
the stuff we may not see on what i like
for us it was one of the best things
that happened to us family wise i i
my kids every day i put a routine for
them to swim 25 laps they had to make 50
shots a day they had to read 20 pages a
day they had to watch an hour of
documentary a day
they came to my office on a daily basis
even though it was shut down we had 25
of our guys working over here to me was
the best thing that happened but also
i'm on the streets and i see a lot of
small businesses
devastate on what happened to them and
challenges in the household husband and
wife fighting trying to figure out money
i saw a lot of that taking place so
i don't know i don't know whether we're
gonna really know what the consequences
are maybe
a decade until we find that to really
see the results but
it is what it is i guess the one
question for you would be
on this topic is if you can touch up on
masks and sanitizers you know i have to
put masks on and
you know we have a very simple system
here at our office when employees work
we have about 100 employees that are
working here
and we have different color wristbands
green is you're comfortable for high
five handshake and fist bumps
you know yellow is you just want to do
one of these things you give me an elbow
and that's it and red is don't get close
to me keep six feet apart
so all our employees are very
comfortable but what are your thoughts
about the mask and hand sanitizers
so let me say this
um
that's going to be the thumbnail just so
you know
you know look uh this is this is about
personal responsibility we recognize a
store
saying no shoes no shirt no no
service hey no mask
uh you know no hand washing no service
um look even if it has
five percent efficacy with
this infective a mischief maker
let's take the five percent but what i
think it really says
to anybody is look i
i realize how serious this is
and me wearing this maybe isn't going to
do much for me
maybe it's not going to do much for you
but at least now you and
i know that there is something going on
and we really ought to pay attention for
this so it to me it's more of a little
sign
saying this is the real deal and
let's you know let's treat it like the
real deal
and i think there's enough there's a
cute little study
not not if you like my studies but so
they took a bunch of mice
and they put them in two cages and glass
all
around except the partition between the
pages
were surgical mass and
the one set of mice were all infected
with covet
and the other set of mice were
uninfected and
they left it like that the mice on the
other side never caught covered
and i think there's enough anecdotes of
the in
uh in texas where the two hairdressers
were infected
yeah and uh they had what 120 clients
maybe 200 clients
none of those people got it i'll give
you a personal example
um at gundry md we film every friday and
we have a skeleton crew
um we everybody is masked
i take my mask off when i'm in front of
the camera
uh people are you know clicking clap
clapboards
and near me and a few weeks ago it's
been a month now
uh one of these individuals and we test
all the time one of these individuals
tested positive
and uh nobody
tested you know caught it uh including
me
and you know and he was around me but he
had a mask on
and so it's it's just so
dumb easy to do it's now
in my bias i've worn a mask all my life
so
it's no big deal for me but the
the idea that mass are going to make you
retain
co2 or cut your oxygen levels i got news
here
there's so many studies of surgeons and
surgical personnel
it doesn't drop your oxygen level it
doesn't increase co2 these are
i don't know where this stuff comes from
but
just for now just it just says hey
let's take this seriously i think i
think the part i mean i saw your video
about masks where you said it doesn't
work i i saw the mask video you did
saying it actually doesn't work
uh but uh you know when you go out and
you're putting it on
i used to get uncomfortable when i would
get on flights and see you know some of
the folks that are traveling from asia
that had masks on like listen that
concerns me they're paranoid you know we
used to say they're overly paranoid
right and now america's becoming the
overly paranoid and uh
i've looked at so many different folks
on what they've said even
even uh uh i think fauci said in one of
the videos he said it doesn't work it
doesn't have anything that's gonna do
it's not gonna prevent
the virus can still get through and i've
seen folks like yourself say the same
thing
but then i wonder why are people wearing
it if the experts are saying it doesn't
work what's the purpose of it is it
i understand social distancing fully i
fully understand
i think yeah i think the main thing is
it's just it's just a sign that you know
come on let's just
keep that distance let's be aware yeah
there
they mass do not filter viral particles
but i think one of the things that's
becoming clear and clear
is that this virus travels
on water droplets and
water droplets are caught by these masks
and i think maybe that's where
uh i was wrong and i'm happy to say it
and i'm i think fouchy early on
he was reading the literature about
virus transmission through mass and
that's what i was reading but he was
also worried
that our frontline workers um
we didn't have enough mass i mean
clearly we didn't have enough mass
and even if mass were minimally
effective it's all we had right yeah
and i'm almost worried that well let's
get those guys to have it instead of us
okay interesting strategy interesting
strategy from his end
uh doc last topic before we wrap up i
got an eight-year-old a seven-year-old
and a three-year-old
i got three kids okay and
up until this point we've gotten every
single vaccine every one of them i've
gotten every single vaccine god knows
i've gotten more vaccines because when
you go into the military they just shoot
you 11 shots in one day so
i'm supposed to grow another third arm
here whatever because they've given me
so many shots when you join the military
1972 they give you three shots so i've
had rfk on you know who robert kennedy
is robert f kennedy who's an
environmental
lawyer but at the same time he's big on
the vaccine and in 1975 i'm curious to
take your ex
you know your your take on this year
in u.s one in 5 000 kids
had autism in 82 that goes to one in
2 500 then 94 is one in 500 then in 2004
1 and 150 then in 2011 1 in 68
today it's 1 in 45 and projected by 2032
to be one in two
what do you think is there any kind of
link between
taking vaccine and you know which
vaccines is the one that's mainly
getting the biggest uh
criticism do you see the link between
the vaccine
and autism have you taken time to study
that topic as far as autism goes
and vaccines go yeah uh
i think there's far better
finger pointing at other causes of
autism than
vaccines now having said that
um aluminum in vaccines
is used as what's called an accelerant
aluminum is calls
our immune system to the scene
and hyper it really
hypers the immune system to get
interested in whatever we just shot you
with
and aluminum by itself is a really
mischievous
neurotoxin and so if you wanted to
criticize
aluminum i'd probably they'd be there
with you
on the other hand one of the things
that's different
than when even my kids who are now grown
were raised and vaccinated is that these
multi vaccines where there's
five ten vaccines simultaneously given
to young children
as a transplant immunologist by
by education i can tell you that
my personal feeling is that has the
potential to overwhelm the immune system
and i that's a new thing we never
used to poly vaccine kids
yeah we'd give you know a mumps vaccine
we'd give a whooping cow expansion we
give a measles vaccine
but we didn't cluster them the way we do
now
nor did we give them much earlier than
life than we do now
but my personal feeling and there's a
lot of evidence in autism
i'll get back to this leaky gut
is in my humble opinion and gut
dysbiosis
in utero in the womb
my uh my guess is to where autism comes
from and there's been some
very fascinating studies out of arizona
giving kids with autism
a fecal transplant or an
oral fecal transplant sometimes called
crapsels and uh
making sure that this becomes implanted
in these kids
and it's placebo controlled and the kids
that got it
had a 50 reduction in their
autistic behavior and it's now lasted
well over two years
after that crapsel so uh
do we have to be
suspicious about the modern system of
vaccinations i would agree
with robert kennedy uh junior
yes um i
you're right when i when i travel to
africa
or india do i have to get vaccinated uh
yes i do do i take the flu vaccine no
never um never um
so why not why don't you great question
because even the adult
flu vaccine the four times flu vaccine
in people over the age of 65 it is
16 effective cdc
vet data from 2018-19 which is the last
year we have so it's like
why would i bother you know i've got a
chance of it working one in six yeah and
if you look at the data yeah all groups
it's 50 effective so
it's like okay i got a coin flip and
i'd rather arm myself against the flu
just like i am arming myself and my
patients against covet 19.
so you also wouldn't take the pfizer
vaccine if it comes out you wouldn't
take that shot
not yet and i'll tell you what um and
the mistake if there was one with the
h1n2
the vaccine was pushed out early
and you may remember and if not google
it there was
a rash of gillian beret
which is that bizarre neurologic
um complication that
some people uh think is attributable to
that vaccine and if you remember several
of
the current trials were paused because
some people
very few got gillian burleigh bray like
symptoms so i think before
we stampede let's and
god bless volunteers please do this
don't
don't get me wrong the only way this
thing is going to stop is with a vaccine
yeah but uh let's you know god bless the
volunteers
but i'm i'm not going to be first in
line for this
um nor do i think i should be first in
line because i think i've got a
pretty doggone good immune system
protection against this
yeah everybody should be taking time
release vitamin c twice a day
uh everybody should be taking elderberry
cursing
zinc and everybody should have a high
vitamin d
level and the last thing is please
please please
do not eat sugar or things that turn
into sugar
and you're you're you're very consistent
with that
you know i mean a glass of orange juice
will suppress your white blood cell
function for
five and a half hours after you drink
the glass of orange juice
yeah it's like why would i want to do
that
we're told that as kids growing up so so
it's interesting you said a lot of
things here that was
so flu shot you're not going to take it
because for your age category 16
1 and 6 and even everybody else across
the board 50 percent
no two covid19 pfizer vaccine because
it's too early maybe we're
hurrying it up let the volunteers go
through it maybe later on you would
consider taking it but to go back to the
vaccine
question is a couple topics that's come
up in our family
by the way have you watched vax the
documentary with belle victory did you
get a chance to watch it
no i haven't watched it yet so sorry
about that yeah
if you haven't i i would suggest it
because and you know who convinced me to
watch it was robert de niro
robert de niro was at this film festival
and i don't know if you know or not his
22 year old son is autistic
and yeah his 22 year old son at the time
i think it was 16 years old at the time
and he was disappointed that they
removed the documentary from it
but he kind of said i think everybody in
the world needs to watch this and do
more research the biggest question for
me is the following
to go from three shots to 72 shots for
my kids
i mean don't you think that's a little
extreme to take that many shots doc
i think i just said that yeah i i
do not like the modern system of
vaccinations
now again we could argue about why
that's a dumb idea we can argue
that it's the aluminum we could argue
that the immune system gets screwed up
or it gets overwhelmed and i think
there's a lot of
different paths that we could go in but
you're right
um this is the first time in history
that we've tried this um
and we just have to i think let's pause
let's hit the pause button
and say gee there are a lot of
interesting things that are happening
and no one's ever had this many
vaccines in anyone's lifetime and
how come certain things are happening
yeah when the conversation comes up
among with your kids with your grandkids
do you tell your
kids yeah it's okay let's take all the
shots or do you tell them to kind of
oh you don't no no i
we we say no let's just you know
take mumps measles rubella
whooping cough but let's stage them got
it
okay we're in the same position here
last but not least for a guy that's
allergic to cats and dogs but loves cats
and dogs
i'm not allergic to [ __ ] to uh shih tzus
but every other dog i'm allergic to
do you have any words of wisdom to
someone who loves animals but is
allergic to cats
so i had a cat in medical school and i
was deathly allergic to my cat
but my cat slept on the top of my head
seriously her name is smoker wonderful
cat
um but i
actually am no longer allergic to cats
uh
one of my practices is getting people
who are
profoundly allergic to anything not be
allergic to them anymore
by the way labradoodles are a fab
fabulous non-allergic dog so get
yourself a labradoodle
we have we have three of them steven
gundry thank you for your time we're
going to put the link below to your
current book
that you have uh the plant paradox but
if the link to
the energy paradox is also available on
amazon we'll put the link below there as
well so others can find you
yeah on there as well and the longevity
paradox was my last best seller i have
four
uh new york times bestsellers on amazon
right now when i grow up i want to be
like you i tell you it's just amazing
what you then your approach
have people told you who you sound like
by the way your voice uh
go ahead tell me harrison ford uh
that one's been one uh i'm frequently
confused um actually with uh who else am
i confused with
uh steve martin steve uh steve martin
uh do i take off my glasses uh some
people i can see that
and and back when i was fat people
stopped me
in central park and thought i was kenny
rogers seriously
you know what kenny rogers yeah was just
saying my wife and i slow danced at our
wedding
lady wow yeah it was written by lionel
richie i think in early 80s 81 or 82
something like that
and people would actually stop me and
ask me to sing
and i actually would i was in my former
life i was a singer
uh so oh my gosh that's classic well
thank you so much uh doc
truly i really enjoyed it the fact that
you were open to talk about all these
different topics
i hope the viewer enjoyed this as much
as i enjoyed it
well thanks for having me on i really
appreciate it and
hey maybe have me on uh in march when
the energy paradox comes in
because you'll be blown away with
what you're going to learn on that one
i'm definitely looking forward to it i'm
definitely looking forward to it
all right take care bye-bye all right
bye-bye we spoke about heart attacks can
you imagine we talked about
we spoke about heart attacks heart
attacks like hey panic attacks against
heart attacks what was your thoughts on
some of the stuff you talked about
whether it was the vaccine the heart
attack the diet
you know whether it was uh coronavirus
mask voucher we talk about a lot of
different things i want to hear your
thoughts comment below and if you
enjoyed this interview
sometimes we can enjoy the interview i
did with dr jason fung if you've not
watched it click over here to watch it
thanks for watching everybody take care
bye